hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg with
the lovely pleased city name
I want my Lauren I want my Lauren from
the channel I Obama and Lauren yes the
YouTube channel she's also an Instagram
I want my Lauren she's also on
everything else snapchat
I want my Lauren wait your Twitter and
your musically Larsen Cheska but her
Facebook I want my life oh my lord
damn promotion through the roof thank
you yeah
you look great today Lauren thank you
thanks I I did a push-up before you came
over that's awesome to feel ready to
feel just as attractive as you are to
the male demographic and I have you
don't cry ever I mean are you are we
watching a crying video right no no the
whole point of this video is you have to
try not to cry oh my god I cry all the
time I am such a crier is this gonna
make me cry I don't know I never seen it
okay it's just it is just a video that I
got sent to me be honest try not to cry
I will try not to cry what happens if we
you cry then we lose the challenge and
you lose respect because you're a [ __ ]
if you cry then don't cry that's not
true I've posted videos where I'm only
crying and it's really backlash don't
make you
[Music]
Thanks
[Music]
my mom would be at all my sporting
events let's say I was playing football
okay my mother would be on the sidelines
at the play on the fields are going one
way like oh my gosh I get hotter with
the other guys ago market is I get
mother I go no I never saw her before my
eyes are the greatest gift my mother
ever gave me she believed in me I've
overdosed on drugs on three occasions
where I should have been dead
Abilene I was kept here for a reason you
show me your friends I will show you
your future how do I know this I hung
out with losers and I became the biggest
lose them all because I gave up
everything except about a little boy
because of light shelves surround myself
my friends drive down with two three
four in the morning we'd be drunk and I
laughing in the car we pulled her from
the house in order to go Marc Marc the
lights I'm like aw man my mother's up
she my mom wouldn't go to bed until she
knew his son was still alive and what
can she say hi Marc
well we should nice girls good mom
shouldn't go to bed [ __ ] can I talk to
you for a minute
no mom I'm tired I'm just gonna go to
bed she's Marc I haven't seen you all
day and all night
can I please talk to you it's a man just
leave me alone
yeah bottom e-explain my bedroom door
and the one person would read to me I
was on a worldwide tour where us
overseas in Japan after my Russell Metro
upstairs my hotel room I fell asleep
there was a knock at my door three
o'clock in the morning I got on the bed
and look for the safety window I could
see his Japanese motor throwing the
dorsum mark you need to call home
there's been an emergency
I wasn't on the hotel room phone I
called back tonight 16 Hey
what's why the mark I don't know how to
drive this I said she's telling you what
happened is our triangle mark did you
tell you I should just say it should
mark your mother died
I just keep going down I ran out of my
hotel room I took the elevator to the
lobby when the doors opened up I guess
way down to the street I think there was
no cars there was no people it's 3
o'clock in the morning and I walked down
the middle of the street in Hiroshima
Japan and I've been looking up and just
say wow I am so sorry
a to hold for a funeral and I'm so
nervous to walk up to her casket so I
just stood way back and I kept looking
from a distance I kept thinking myself
please wake up please get up
and then I finally got the nerve to
lockup torque and there's I got closer I
could see the most the first Hahnemann
she's so beautiful she was dressed in
one of me she's like an angel we just
stood over the sugar
mom you are my hero I don't think I am
everything I hope to do is come to you
you love me so much you gave me a life
you're the only one that ever was used
to me compared I can't drunk by then hi
again
stupid binding and losers full o she
ever want to do to me
who is it to talk to no mom I wish you
see what I'm doing like map and a better
son we are defined by our choices but if
you surround yourself a people involved
in drugs and alcohol pills it's a dead
end
I'm not here to preach here I'm here to
tell you I live that life it leads to
broken hearts broken relationships
broken dreams and death for what yeah I
if you have a mother or a father when
you go home tell mom what she loved she
my whole life was about being rich and
famous happy millionaires and win the
race I wouldn't waste expense my
marriage my family my friends for us to
be all in the world and learn what is
truly important and that is how precious
this gift of life is and our families
and how quickly it can be taken away
she no longer live in time I live in
moment she's not was in your pocket that
matters it's what's in your heart that
truly matters
love love is just a word until somebody
comes along and gives it meaning you
you're the me ah
[Music]
alright I'm a little mad at you right
now because you got film or video like
oh [ __ ] let me do this Rick no I tried
really hard not to cry
I like lift out honestly nope yeah no
Codell deers
yeah that's the [ __ ] up challenge
because when you're stuffed when you
feel like crying you should try okay I
was like about to cry that I was like
always try not to cry then I started
thinking this is why it's a [ __ ]
because I should be able to just cry Oh
got teary-eyed you guys here yet I've
got red and put a little little drop
right here Oh God but nice how you
you're there they got you oh yeah that
acidities are the videos they show
children so they won't do drugs to play
yeah like that's nice but I'll prepare
right now like this is what they do to
scare children
yeah you're gonna be like him without
going into too much of my personal life
like I've already done before I could do
my chin do it first time when it comes
to crying I got teasing fail it comes to
crying I used to be on a lot of
medication uh-huh you see on a lot of
pills and I got off of all them around
March of last year one about the full
year of it off all my meds I was on for
many years and would help me like cope
and and deal with situations more in the
u.s. depressed is actually crying uh-huh
because I've heard that crying releases
more endorphins and then any medication
out there that again that actually does
make you feel better in the end
thank you yeah oh yeah I just want you
to feel better about my attention here
but it comes to the mom stuff like oh
yeah as sincere in my mom a few months
ago she was really close
she's always taking care of me and I
felt like she was the one who was the
bread one she was a breadwinner in the
family she was the one who provided all
the time
she was always working all the time so I
felt like I was like this disappointment
in her life I might even know how big
this channel got I was always so big
your heart I felt like I was just like a
loser in her eyes and I had to like talk
to her about that like was this core
feeling that I had so I just like ball
to my mom a lot and so you know he's
like talking about this this
conversation he didn't get a hat with
her and I'm like yeah I shed a lot of
tears a few months ago because I had
that conversation with her about all
these things of how great she is to me
but also how I feel like she liked maybe
I wasn't a good son you know and yeah
not sure more often we're better than so
yeah we're more connected than ever I
miss my mom now all right your mom's at
home yeah you're so lucky that you get
to ear close to your mom yeah well those
are happening till recent finding it
close like physical yeah yeah
we're coming in New York New York way
back there across the country so we'll
really touched you about this what
really touched me just his reaction just
just keep just like his reaction to the
whole thing and how he was saying that
he saw their things is more important
and then he realized and just maybe
think is like oh god I'm trying to go
after my dreams but the thing that's
more important is family and I don't
really see them very much and then I was
like started today there's like no it's
easy to let working goals distract you
from those who matter most yeah that
happen many a time yeah definitely Sally
but even here in your story about about
your mom makes me think like I don't
think I've ever had that conversation
with my mom Marie conversation I had
that conversation like I don't know how
you do it for years and years I was in
therapy and I was talking about service
like I feel like I got five of my mom's
any any time I had like a relationship
issue or a connection with a girl if
those are some mom issue I had man for
years I've been avoiding this talk many
my whole life I'm like even when I
became aware that I probably should talk
to my mom I just was like I know how my
mom will respond I know exactly how my
mom will respond to talk I go down the
way how anyone thinks it will and I
talked with her the first time ever
where she got very emotional - she
started crying she started and it's like
she told me how much she like really
loved me and it's like I didn't really
feel that nurturing or anything for so
chaotic at the time so she she had this
chance to express that to me I did feel
a repaired happening in my heart now I
went on yeah we change right now when
I'm by myself I'm on this uh-huh you
know it's try not to cry from trying to
repress which is stupid but trying to
repress but by myself I'm like like I'm
very much that kind of crime I'll just
cry yeah but if there's someone in the
room you know I've been here in the
movie theatres and you start to cry or
maybe like a guy crying it's like
whenever I'm very I cry there's a girl
next to me I wish you go Shh you're
crying
oh are you crying I guess I kinda shut
to cry around like unless I'm opening up
about something but if there's like a
video or a movie moving my emotions I
get shy about that Oh
anyway yeah that's today's fun video for
you guys yeah thank you and where did it
try not to cry oh you feel you can
subscribe to the real rejects but most
importantly you got to subscribe to this
humble soul over here Lauren Francesca
on the channel I want my Lauren all the
links are social media are on the
description box she constantly live
streams like pretty much every day on so
many things she's one of the busiest
most hard-working women I know one man
woman was the work where was his woman
woman one man one man oh woman I know
she's one of the hearts working ladies
in the field so go check her stuff out
she deserves more success than most
people I need some so thank you
nope wrong alright time to do the next
video you can touch up your makeup if
you